good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight happy Monday not a lot
of Americans pay attention to European
politics unless they're very bored or
work at some Think Tank and that's
understandable but it's a shame really
because if you look closely what's
happening in Europe you can learn a lot
about what's Happening Here
despite the castles and the funny
accents and the smelly cheese Europe is
not actually that different from the
United States at least in this way
European leaders run their countries
pretty much the same way our leaders run
our country the Yammer on endlessly
about democracy but then at the same
time they do their best to avoid
democracy's most basic requirements like
free speech and representative
government
a few years ago the prime minister of
Italy at the time Paulo gentilloni
bragged to the world economic Forum
about his plans to quote bring more
social justice to the country by which
he meant importing many more thousands
of poorly educated economic migrants
from the third world into Italy we are
very open on migration he said we are
saving lives at sea ooh saving lives huh
congratulations you're such a good
person
but the question is and it's a relevant
question in a democracy what are the
people who live in Italy that would be
your constituents think of that idea
well as the Prime Minister explained he
didn't care quote a demand for more
democracy not only is wrong it's even
dangerous
you following this you run a country in
the name of the people you're not a king
you're a democratically elected leader
you run it in the name of the people who
live there but at the same time it's
quote dangerous to allow the opinions of
those people to influence your decisions
does that sound familiar oh it does
because it's exactly the kind of
democracy that we live in which is to
say a fake one
in fact there is no majority in any
country on planet Earth that thinks open
borders are a good idea or that
considers global warming the single
biggest problem or that thinks it's wise
to quarantine the entire population
because of a flu virus no large group of
people anywhere wants these things
but in the west everybody gets them
anyway because politicians don't care
what you think your opinion is dangerous
shut up racist
so it goes without saying this can't
last a system like this cannot endure
forever because it's inherently unstable
you can't tell people they're in charge
of their own government it's a democracy
we promise and then ignore over decades
they're most strongly held opinions on
things that matter that doesn't work
long term they will Rebel guaranteed and
the best you can hope for is that they
will do it peacefully
in Italy they seem to be doing just that
this summer a conservative populist
called Georgia Maloney started showing
up with strong support in the polls
Millennia was no radical reviews would
have seemed perfectly ordinary just a
decade ago but because she resolutely
refused to bow to the twin gods of
climate and mass migration people
panicked the president of the European
Commission in fact on camera commanded
Italians not to vote for her watch
so we'll see if things go in a difficult
direction I've spoken about Hungary and
Poland we have tools if things go in the
right direction and people as a body
that is always
where always governments have to be
accountable to play an important role
oh if things go in the wrong directions
in other words if voters disobey quote
we have tools oh you do do you well that
sounds like a threat because of course
it is a threat but it turns out Italians
are so desperate they no longer care
they're not afraid and they're not
afraid because neoliberalism which that
lady is just espousing has destroyed
their country Energy prices in some
places in Italy are now up more than 400
percent over last year why well a
pointless war in Ukraine and
self-destructive climate policy it's not
an accident and everyone knows it
meanwhile parts of Italy are becoming
flat out dangerous that hasn't happened
before outside of Sicily but it's
happening now why everyone knows why and
government statistics show why it's
migrants who are driving much of the
crime a huge amount of the crime
so these aren't Mysteries but you're not
allowed to acknowledge them in public
period in some places it's illegal
but Maloney is one of the very few
politicians who doesn't care and has
been willing to say the obvious the
truth out loud
and as a result of that because she's
been willing to say what everybody
actually knows last night her party
called Brothers of Italy won an
overwhelming victory in Italy they took
both majority majorities in the houses
of Parliament
so by Italian standards in fact by
American Standards this is a revolution
but unlike most revolutions the person
at the front of it can actually explain
what she's about
she can articulate it in a way people
understand she's smart
this is part of the speech she gave
earlier this year that led to last
night's results watch
our rights are under attack the
sovereignty of our nation is under
attack the prosperity and well-being of
our families under attack the education
of our children is under attack in front
of these people understand that in this
age the only way of being Rebels is to
preserve what we are the only way of
being Rebels is to be conservatives
they will try to take everything away
from us but they can take away Who We
Are
and you know what
cherishing who we are
knowing what we stand for is all we need
to face this challenge
she's not kidding
she's as serious as the moment we are
currently living through
our rights are under attack she said the
sovereignty of our nation is under
attack and critically quote the
prosperity and well-being of our
families is under attack and that's true
that's why it's resonant because it's
real and not just in Italy it's true
here American families are facing the
very same Onslaught from the very same
poisonous ideologies the difference he
is that in this country it's rarely
acknowledged except on the fringes
monies not in the fringes she's the new
prime minister of Italy she will be and
she's saying it out loud contrast that
to what's happening in the United States
House Republicans just spelled out what
they're running on it's a document
called the commitment to America it's
fine probably not much in it you
disagree with it have you heard of it no
you probably haven't
you probably even read it nobody really
cares why because there's nothing real
in it there's not a single word in that
document about the attacks on the
American family that you see every day
that's at the center of most people's
concerns
how are my kids will they have a life
that resembles mind
that was called the American dream does
it still exist will they be able to
afford to live the way they grew up well
they have the opportunities that we had
no
people are upset about that why wouldn't
they be
but nobody says it
and that's odd because we know and now
it's been proven that when politicians
are brave enough to tell the truth about
what's actually happening they tend to
be rewarded for it
once again here's the incoming prime
minister of Italy and as you watch this
ask yourself if you would vote for a
candidate like this if you had the
chance in our country
um
domander
foreign
so that's the person who's being
described all over American television
including on channels that should know
better as quote far right that's far
right really because she acknowledges
that American families are under attack
of course they are you think it's
accidental no and she explains why and
it's simple if you want to establish to
tell totalitarian control over a country
of course you have to destroy the family
first because nobody with deep family
loyalty the one thing every person
should have no one who has that will
ever pledge absolute obedience to a
politician why would you so if you want
absolute obedience you have to sever
Family Ties and that's why State schools
brainwash your children with values that
you despise and then instruct your
children to turn you in as a thought
criminal if you object
that's happening it's not your
imagination and it's happening for a
reason wokeness is not just a political
ideology it's not just something
annoying that emerged on college
campuses that we can ignore
it's a state religion that supplants
actual religion which is also being
destroyed there's a reason the strip
bars and the liquor stores and the weed
dispensaries stayed open undercovered
but the churches didn't
if you can't draw the connection between
those dots you're missing it but baloney
didn't miss it she understands it
perfectly watch
only a few months ago
European Union bureaucrats wrote a
document hundreds of pages long
telling us that in order to be inclusive
we have to exclude all references to
Christmas
Jesus Mary and all Christian names were
to be removed from all official
communication will we surrender in front
of this
no we will not we will fight it we will
fight it Standing Tall
so the hatred family the hatred religion
and you don't actually have to put up
with it because it's a democracy and
you're supposed to be in charge you
being the population that's a radical
message God family country that's not
radical it's hard to imagine a more
wholesome message a more pro-human
platform
fascists don't believe in God because
God is a rival to their power of course
this is a person publicly professing
faith in God that's so scary but it is
so scary it's so scary to the people
running and benefiting from our current
system and why is that she's not the
first person to say this people have
said it before but she's just been
rewarded for saying it that's the point
the population likes it this is what
they actually want they're not that
worried about global warming they don't
want open borders they think the woke
stuff is absurd they want to say what
they think
and now it's obvious because she just
won
and so even in this country the people
running and benefiting from a deeply
corrupt and doomed system are hysterical
watch the reaction to that
I want to start today by talking about a
politician on the right who we should
all be worried about who's on the rise
today a politician who has brushed off
accusations of fascism what separates us
from let's say
Italy who elected a a fascist she is
from fascist Roots they far right
political party whose roots go back to
post World War II neo-fascists a party
that has its roots in Italian fascism
it's roots in Italian fascism
Define that for us if you would Joe
Scarborough oh sorry you're an idiot you
can't but the point is fascist means
unacceptable whatever this chick is
saying you're not allowed to agree with
they're very worried that that many
Italians do agree with it so she has to
be completely unacceptable don't read
further she's a fascist and in case you
missed the theme a recent New York Times
piece I'm lonely mentioned fascism or
fascist
29 times not a subtle newspaper
apparently she's on the verge of
invading Poland we should be worried
watch this
they said it could never happen again
100 years ago Mussolini marching on Rome
plunging the country into two decades of
dictatorship an alliance with Hitler and
a second world war today the fascist
party is gone but many say these are
their political heirs the brothers of
Italy once on the fringes they've
ballooned into the biggest party in the
country now their leader Georgia Maloney
is poised to head the most hard-right
government since ilduche the 45 year old
Firebrand insists she's no fascist just
a proud conservative and nationalist
comfortable nevertheless with some of
the Hallmarks of Italian fascism like
this motto
God Fatherland and family
God family country well that's pretty
scary not a word about climate or equity
but again it's their hysteria and their
total unwillingness to ask obvious
questions that lets you in on the secret
which is they're panicked because they
know the current system is doomed and in
fact what happened last night in Italy
is the best case scenario for them
because it was a peaceful transfer of
power that's a good thing that's what
you want in a democracy people should be
allowed to have some influence on the
priorities of the government that claims
to represent them
and when they speak in an election the
people who've been repudiated have a
moral obligation to pause just for one
second and ask why didn't they like what
I was offering them they have a right to
an opinion in fact their opinion is at
the center of our system this democracy
but they never ask themselves that they
never take any blame whatsoever they
didn't in 2016 when Trump got elected
they immediately blamed Putin
or Macedonian bot Farms they never blame
themselves and so they never learned a
single thing from what happened
that's exactly what's happening not
simply in American television but also
in Italy and also in the European Union
the bureaucrats who drove Italians
to seek a change peacefully at The
Ballot Box
are completely unwilling to learn from
that vote they'll just keep ramming
their unpopular garbage down the throats
of a deeply ungrateful Nation until
there's an actual Rebellion let's hope
that doesn't happen
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight